victor davis hanson is a historian a
senior fellow at uber institution and
one of our favorite guests professor
thanks so much for coming on what
conclusions do you draw from this
spectacle
well i think that usually in normal
times tucker that we don't do insane
things like let people out with no bail
or do not prosecute people who are
arrested or let felons out of prison but
these are confined to the campus
critical race theory critical legal
theory critical penal theory but i don't
know whether it was coveted or the
lockdown or george floyd or the 120 days
of rioting in summer of 2020 or the
strange 102 male in ballots or the biden
left-wing agenda but these academic
theories got mainstream into actual
policies of defunding the police and
letting criminals out of jail and et
cetera and we lost deterrence so the
criminal today says in a cost-benefit
analysis it's it's in my interest to
commit a crime because i'm not going to
pay the price for
and then we can't deal with that reality
but if if you're talking about white
supremacy we would like to go to certain
data areas to confirm that so when we
look at rare interracial crimes which
are pretty rare
african americans by a great number or
disproportionately commit them against
whites versus
uh whites versus blacks that wouldn't be
possible under a white supremacist
nation or if you look at murders and
violent assaults
african americans in cases of murders
are between 50 and 60 percent even
though they only make up 12 percent of
the population and whites are
underrepresented if you look at hate
crimes
uh african americans are overrepresented
and whites are underrepresented i'm not
trying to justify any of this i'm just
giving you the data but that data is
toxic to these theories so people try to
suppress it or they massage it or they
contextualize it but we're never going
to get to helping the people who really
need the help in the inner city the
innocence if we don't stop this crime
wave and a lot of it has to do with
african-american males who feel
one way or another there's no deterrent
left and as far as the white supremacy
we recall
remember lloyd austin and mark milly
gave us lecture after lecture about it
and so we but one thing they didn't do
they never gave us any data they didn't
say here's the pentagon's data here's
the enlisted ranks we have an epidemic
where white soldiers are committing
interracial
acts of hostility at a greater number
than hispanics or latinos vis-a-vis
other rates they never told us that but
since they wanted to dwell on
race race race and proportional
representation which i think is very
dangerous in a multi-racial society
maybe whites are more violent in the
sense that they're more likely to be in
combat units
about double their numbers of the
general population and white males died
at twice their numbers in afghanistan
and iraq nobody ever talks about that if
that's what they mean by they took a gun
and they went after the enemy and that
makes them dangerous i don't know
uh if that's what they intended but
finally tucker they don't
the left doesn't have an agenda in
november so we're going to hear roe
versus wade we're going to hear the
electoral college is
racist filibusters we're going to hear
white supremacy white supremacy but and
we're never going to hear here's what we
we can do for energy here's what we can
do for deterrence of foreign policy
here's what we're going to do for
inflation none of that so this is what
it's all about
it's pretty simple if you improve
people's lives no matter what color they
are they'll vote for you and if you
don't they won't i don't know why they
haven't figured that out
they haven't victory dave's handsome
don't want to go back to a tribal racial
society we want to be
content of our character not the color
of our skin amen thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight